comentarios insultantes sobre el profeta
islámico provocaron una ola de protestas
en la india y en el mundo islámico la
semana pasada la portavoz del partido
gobernante india reuters arma hizo
insultos contra mahoma ahora las
autoridades intentan controlar las
protestas en varias ciudades del país
cerrando dos pueblos y tiendas en
cachemira la región de mayoría musulmana
queremos su castigo ya sea respira bing
o no pour deben ser castigados para que
sintamos que hay una democracia que es
un país demócrata y no drive angry los
comentarios han ofendido musulmanes en
todo el mundo provocando protestas en
sus países vecinos como aquí en
bangladesh
el gobierno indio está volviendo a la
ciudadanía de los musulmanes por lo
tanto estamos advirtiendo al gobierno la
comunidad musulmana mundial está unida
pedimos a todo el mundo que boicotee los
productos sirios
en indonesia y malasia convocaron a los
embajadores de india en sus países
[Música]
si la embajada y el gobierno indio no se
disculpan y aclaran la situación
organizaremos la protesta más importante
hasta que la embajada abandone este país
de mayoría musulmana
[Música]
la portavoz del jp no por su arma fue
suspendida tras sus comentarios y
expulsada del partido pero no es la
primera vez que al gobierno indio está
acusado de discriminación religiosa las
protestas recuerdan la larga historia
anti musulmana en india como las
revueltas de mumbai en 1992 causada por
la destrucción de la mezquita de babri
que dejaron 900 muertos